c'est le ce qui se passe dans le jura
c'est le reflet de ce qui se passe en
france au niveau de l'industrie
c'est donc ça dépend de choix ne s'est
pas c'est pas irrémédiable c'est des
choix que jacob delafon ce parce que on
a gagné beaucoup d'argent sans investir
ici ont choisi de licencier en tout cas
on est on imprime la volonté de
licencier avant de réfléchir à des
solutions alternatives
là il faut que les salariés s'en mêle
premièrement et que le gouvernement lui
impose d'autre choix donc ya pas de sais
pas je les dis souvent là que vides a
bon dos ce qui est en jeu aujourd'hui
c'est comment pour les pour le medef ces
commandes augmentent les dividendes aux
actionnaires
pour nous c'est comme en non seulement
préserver l'emploi nous on le développe
ces deux choix politiques qui
s'affrontent avec un gouvernement qui
vous l'avez noté penche plutôt du côté
du medef
travailler tous les jours il ya un peu
ce textile
non il ya des tonnes dans toute une
série d'entreprises c'est le manque
d'investissement c'est le manque de
considération pour les salariés qui est
qui est responsable de la situation et
que la commune a bon dos et puis en même
temps on maltraite encore les salariés
fassent matin on dit qu'à pas de boulot
mais du jour au lendemain vous appellent
finalement faut venir bosser demain où
finalement tu viens pas beau seulement
c'est pas c'est pas digne de notre
époque ce traitement des salariés donc
il faut aussi revoir les conditions de
travail l'organisation du travail et
écouter plus les salariés enfants tout
casser j'en étais convaincu mais ça m'a
ici dans lors de ces échanges dame a
conforté
est ce son maître la meilleure solution
circonstances actuelles
[Musique]
évidemment que on a on est dans un pays
où le modèle social qui a été tant
critiqué y compris par notre président
de la république qui fait ses preuves
même s'il est attaqué le chômage de
longue durée c'est une solution mais il
doit pas être conditionné à des accords
de compétitivité ou de je-ne-sais-quoi
qui consiste en même temps qu on obtient
les aides de licencier des salariés
cette période elle doit être elle doit
être comment dire permettre aux salariés
de se former camarades me disais ça fait
quatre ans que je suis là j'ai pas eu de
formation donc pour se former
il faut pas travailler il faut aller en
formation ça permet d'ailleurs de donner
du boulot à ceux qui n'ont pas ou qui
sont au sommet spatiale il faut changer
l'organisation du travail dans cette
période et qui sait le moment
contrairement à ce qu'on pense
d'embaucher des jeunes en alternance en
apprentissage parce que il ya des
salariés qui ont moins de boulot et bien
ils peuvent transmettre leur savoir
faire à des jeunes qui cherchent du
boulot et qui sont en formation devrait
donc on a des propositions mais pour
l'instant
la politique du gouvernement et des
grandes entreprises c'est joli sentissi
d'abord et je réfléchis après nous on
propose le contraire on réfléchit et on
trouve des solutions pour pas licencier
tout à coup
quelque chose comme ça qui
je sais ce que j'ai rappelé la direction
de l'entreprise que pour l'instant
embaucher les alternants ça leur coûtait
rien qu'ils en profitent mais on
construit pas son avenir avec un cdd
avec un hypothétique promesse d'embauché
ces aides
elles doivent être conditionnées à une
embauche en cdi est-ce qu'il ya que avec
un cdi qu'on construit sa vie vous avez
vu les 600 700 mille chômeurs de plus du
printemps c'est des gens qui étaient des
jeunes surtout qui était cdd qui était
intérimaire
il faut que le cdi soit la règle est
donc ce qu'on demande au gouvernement
oui pour des aides mais à la fin de
l'alternance ou de l'apprentissage c'est
un cdi dans l'entreprise qui vous a
accueilli là aussi c'est d'assez le ça
dépend du gouvernement des aides sans
condition eh bien ça donne
derrière on prend l'argent et on
licencie et qui après on a des milices
qui lie qui montre du doigt en disant
c'est pas bien ce que vous faites face à
ça faut arrêter avec ça